Some of the white men had lived at Fort Yukon for several years.
They liked to watch the Native Americans' dogs, especially White Fang,...
...attack and kill the newcomers' dogs.
One of these men was called Beauty.
Every day, he gave the dog a beating.
Almost beaten to death daily by this bad man,...
...White Fang became more dangerous to other dogs.
Beauty used White Fang as a fighting dog.
He became famous as, "The Fighting Wolf,"...
...and men came from near and far to watch him fight other dogs.
Scott had heard about White Fang.
He knew he was one of the best lead sled dogs ever.
"I'll buy that dog from you," he told Beauty.
"A hundred and fifty dollars."
White Fang slowly got better and during this time, he did not let anyone near him.
"He's going to be useless," Scott said to Matt.
"I've wasted my money."
"I'll get my gun and shoot him."
"Give him more time," Matt said.
"He doesn't like you because of that man, Beauty."
"He needs to learn that we won't hurt him."
Every day, Scott touched the dog.
White Fang began to like being touched.
He began to like this god who gave him meat, touched him gently, and never beat him.
He knew that this god was different from all the others.
As the days passed, White Fang began to love Scott.
He lived the rest of his life quietly with Scott and his family,...
...a much gentler, and much loved wolf dog.